this podcast and every other podcast
that I make is supported by patreon you
can request certain actors as guests
submit questions for the show and
actually this episode of patreon's got a
little pre-show a few extra minutes at
the top they also get outtakes and
unedited content too so if you'd like to
support these very independent podcasts
check the link in the description Hello
everyone welcome to another episode of
voice acting 101 today I am joined by
Ben Ben who are you and why are you here
um my name is Ben and as you already
said so already we're off to a flying
stars
um and I'm here because I am an actor
who voices Clive rossfield in Final
Fantasy 16 and
um you yeah yeah he's around at the
moment people like him
um and uh yeah I I met you and I spoke
to you and said how much of a fan I was
of of your work and stuff and you said
why didn't you come and talk about your
work
um and here we are and here we are that
is the magic of two people having a
normal conversation any it's possible
you said that Clive's pretty popular
which I would agree with
um you worked on the game for quite some
time uh I did I I
feel like Clive has exceeded my
expectations in terms of popularity do
you have any any anticipation for how
people are going to react to the
character before it actually came out
not at all no I think uh because I
didn't
know anything about I mean I obviously
knew all about Final Fantasy I'm a huge
fan but just the idea of having
expectations of how popular that
character would be I just couldn't
really figure out what the scale would
be if that makes sense like what I did I
I couldn't possibly comprehend that
millions of people would play it I knew
they would
but I didn't know how that would kind of
come back in the feedback sense
um I guess it's like if you try to
picture a million people in a room and
you kind of can't it just becomes a
number yeah what does it mean imagine
all those people in a field you know
like terrified I don't like that field
at all yeah also how much land do you
own if they're all in the field it's mad
how big is the field I have so many
questions yeah so much are they very
small people a very large field what is
this you can't unpack it it'll just give
you anxiety yeah and that's and that's
the inside of my brain there so that's
how I feel about Clive is millions of
people very very small people in a very
large field
um so what has the response largely been
I I know what my perspective is but
yours is a very unique one obviously
playing Clive yeah I I have loved
so at the beginning before it came out I
really kind of wanted people to lean
into the bit that resonated with me most
when we were making this which is
Chloe's vulnerability
um which I I very much wore on my sleeve
when I was making this game of like he
is a a tough old hero he's going to do
all the hero stuff that you you see in
video games but he he he suffers a lot
and I wanted that to be as visceral and
real as possible for people and quite
ugly in many ways which I like
um and
um that's what I love that immediately
the response was like Clive seems quite
real for a for a protagonist and and a
lot of people have latched on to that
um but to be honest the bit that really
people have leaned in on is all the
memes it's all him being a baby girl him
him with his chest all all of the stuff
he's so uh he is so hot unavoidably so
it's just it's distracting
um and uh yeah I I love that that I mean
I love that he's attractive
um he's he's a he's cool and he's I
think it's nice actually that you have
you see that level of vulnerability in a
guy that attractive also true yeah
really quite cool right and um I would
say that he's the most relatable Final
Fantasy villain from my perspective and
I can't imagine that's easy so like you
mentioned before we started recording
that you worked on this for four years
yes and it spans three different periods
of Clive's life how do you bring
complexity to a character over that span
of time both in the game and in the real
world like do you ever have trouble
keeping up with Where You Are
yeah yeah you do I mean to say I didn't
it would be just the biggest lie over
four years
um I think you have to
um
I think what because it was such a long
period of time the kind of like where
does Ben end and Clive begin kind of
went a bit like that a lot
um it got to a point where I didn't
need
as much direction as maybe I did in the
first couple of couple of sessions
because the first couple of months
really where we all there was kind of a
real
General consensus of of who he was and
where we wanted him to go and I think
those scenes where you see him at his
weakest those ones where you go oh
that's quite
that's you know that's that's some snot
crying there Clive
um uh they came about because of how
comfortable we all were in the room I
was very lucky to work with some amazing
performance directors
um Hannah price only chance Morgan
Rushton
um and you know obviously Koji and and
um John Taylor in in Japan yeah this is
I was talking to Koji about it this is
the first Final Fantasy that's recorded
English first as well which is like a
new undertaking for that entire
franchise that's obviously many games
long at this point a whole 17 of them I
know there's here we are and I and I'm
thrilled that like I got to do that
because I don't think I'm
I've never upped up to this point and I
probably won't again have that amount of
creative freedom over a character to
make those choices so how did you uh
like leaning into that how did you
actually get the role of of Clive and uh
going even further back how did you
start out as an actor
um so I just wrote them letters every
day just so your harassment is what you
it's it's and it just works it really
does so please
they love it yeah please always like to
send them like bloody towels and things
like that
um I it was this is just the most
kind of unremarkable story and it was
just a normal audition I didn't know
anything about
I've said this before but I auditioned
for another character they then said
would you like to do read this I sight
read it it was it resonated with me and
then
two weeks better Edition I suppose yeah
it really like and like I'm not I'm not
an experienced voice actor I'm not like
one of these seasoned Pros who has a
thousand credits to their name and you
know Legions of fans and worked on loads
of things and that is such a skill
I'm not like that I'm just a kind of
communal Garden stage and Screen accent
like and they audition they wanted that
when they came in because they knew that
we were originating these roles yeah
um and
um yeah I I went in and
and it was it was scary at first because
well I didn't really know they just said
come in now in two weeks time and record
Final Fantasy 16 and don't tell anyone
by the way this is your favorite
franchise don't tell anyone well I
assume that you also in the audition it
didn't even indicate that it was Final
Fantasy 16 right they tend to be pretty
they cut out all of the code words and
I'm so good whenever I go in for
auditions I guess the game every single
time I've seen tons of them for uh
different Star Wars games and they
always just write Templar like okay I
know what this is
still Templar uh you are a Jedi
but I feel like Final Fantasy 16
especially probably would be pretty hard
to guess because it's totally very
different from previous games in the
series as well Victor I I thought it was
I they said it was a big fantasy RPG
series and I originally I think I
originally thought it was going to be
held in ring or like a Lord of the Rings
sort of thing like I was and I thought
that's maybe what it is and
um nope
um when they took all them took all the
names away I think dominance were called
demonites in it
um and Clyde was called Clint
um I love that like Clive with a bit of
spoiler
yeah he um I I just didn't know anything
and then when they gave me the I think
the script they gave me the script in
advance and they said here is 673 Pages
that's really uncommon yes the whole
script wow did you read the screenplay
no I did not I did not because they were
like you're coming in tomorrow and
recording and things change right that's
that this was the this was the the
script that had been translated back in
up to that point into 20 now were
written
um not translated but like written with
Koji and um uh my hero and uh it was in
a screenplay form uh and it's very
unusual it was very very unusual and
obviously that script has been expanded
and moved and changed because that's
what game development is
um but uh yeah it was a it was it was a
crazy old thing and uh and then I went
in and just started saying lines do you
remember what your expectations were
like on your first day what did you what
did you think it was going to be versus
what it was I thought I was gonna get
fired I thought I was gonna get fired
every day every day I lost my voice like
I ruined my voice with like the first
yeah um two days
um because I was like what do you want
me to do or do anything please don't
fire me
um and
I learned over the four years just the
most incredible amount of voice control
that was your absolute Pro now like
working on that for four years is that
you are a seasoned voice actor no that's
a long time so much well we I worked out
with um uh Martin Vaughan who is the
casting director at side UK
um which is where we've recorded it
um inside where it's where they recorded
a lot of cyberpunk Assassin's Creed
there is also a side la which I think is
where I recorded cyberpunk actually
there you go there you go so cider cider
um they're very very experienced and
they now have offices and places all
across the world yeah and Martin who's
been the casting director there for
years and years and years I was having a
chat with him in the cafeteria one day
as you do and um he was saying that they
reckon that by the time I was done on
this I had I was the one
that is my dog
hello
that's Milton can we bring Milton
thoughts Milton what are your thoughts I
can't
I don't know why he's doing this I'm
sorry you're embarrassing Milton you're
embarrassing I promise you it adds to
the quality of the podcast
the better I'll go and get him in a bit
and I'll just I'll use him use him for
likes
um yeah I uh we worked out that I think
I had been the one actor who'd worked on
a single project for the longest amount
of time a single project and done the
most amount of hours because we weren't
doing it wasn't like we were doing 40
lines an hour we were doing a lot less
like a lot less and we weren't doing it
until it was right
um and so sometimes we would really
would just really go down and down and
down and down because we would have
these head cams on you know and it's a
lot of the all this all the cut
sequences that you see are just you know
our facial movements shoved to Clive's
face or Jill's face or Sid's face
have them on every time
um so
um I would say 50 of the time I did
um so for you know the big big detailed
cut sequences that you see the big
action pieces the big
um
the big key moments I would have those
on
um and then uh then the other time would
be for kind of like all the side quests
or the party chat or the stuff like that
um when you can't see a mountain you're
like wow look at that mountain
I think it broke the record for most
cutscenes in a triple A game I think
most hours of cutscenes Maybe oh that's
a lot which is also a lot for you though
like I assume you did uh pcap and mocap
uh no I did so I didn't do I didn't do
there's he just ran along oh I saw him
Cameo yeah get him Big Bob for that
little guy yeah he's expecting the
bigger dog such a small boy he's like
this big he's a lovely boy
um and now you've done his barking he's
done
um he's contributed he he was in he was
in the studio actually in the booth when
I would do lines for toggle really yeah
that's so cute he is he's so nice so
he's technically toggle
yeah he didn't record any of the lines
he isn't he he's he he's not a wolf for
your performance purposes
Canon he will always I Cannon toggle
yeah absolutely
um yeah he's I'm gonna start him he's
start gonna go to conventions and stuff
and just start signing stuff with his
poor I think about selling my dog out
all the time there's like a huge market
for like pet influences I'm like does he
need it though there really is
I regret not doing like it because he is
he's stupidly cute he's a tiny Yorkshire
Terrier which is the most beautiful face
and I just think God if I had the time
and the willpower and the patience I
should have started like an Instagram
I'd have got so much free dog food but
you still can
no I I can't be bothered
that's my attitude to almost everything
I want to do yeah you know what I I
can't be
that is yeah that's about that's that's
happened to me now in my life I'm like I
could easily do that but I don't want to
what if I didn't yeah yeah let's do that
more actually uh what was the question I
just asked you oh uh you did not do
motion capture so Clive's
um
I know this happens often Clive's body
is probably multiple people yes
it's yeah usually like stuntman of
various rights also brilliant brilliant
motion capture actors so those two I
know there were two recording processes
that happened throughout
um because there was just so much that
had to be done when we first started
there was motion capture happening in
Japan and then there was also motion
capture happening in Hungary
um and so there were lots of brilliant
brilliant actors who were out there
doing the scenes you know in in place in
situ and then
we would watch those scenes back
and then interesting we would then they
recorded before you for you to then add
facial captures so yeah we were it was
doing all of this it was doing all at
the same time and then what I would see
in front of me is like a screen of the
scene and then I would essentially do it
like ADR
um that's super interesting wow I've
never heard of that yeah it was and it
was it was a process a a full-on process
yeah uh but
um that was that was part of it I mean
there were just so many different
versions it was such an amazing learning
process but that's kind of what we ended
up settling on and
um what I really love about this was
that I got to do stuff with Ralph
Einstein who plays Sid and I got to do
stuff with Susanna Fielding who plays
Geraldine
um that was the coolest part was getting
to be there and us doing stuff together
so early on before we saw any of it we
actually did we actually did some stuff
without seeing it and just kind of a lot
of the stuff that you see in the game
isn't us like dubbing over anything it's
just us just playing and I think that's
where you that's where you see the most
free stuff yeah you know I think that
like you get that real chemistry and
people have really responded to Clive
and Sid's relationship which I love
definitely and
and I love Ralph he's great he is just
game for Game for fun
um also very hot Sid
everybody's hot they knew what they were
doing everyone's hot everyone's sexy yes
excessively I'm a fan I described it as
sarcastically attractive
yeah that's that's I remember just
seeing every time I'd see more and more
characters in this game and going of
course of course
that's very good uh I asked you this but
we sort of glossed over it you gave me a
brief answer but I'd love to dig into it
so sorry I'll make it longer this time
yeah can you please answer better yeah
thank you I will do yeah you're so
welcome the question was how you got
started you mentioned uh theater and
screen but what does that mean how did
you how did you start acting
um do you mind if I have a glass of wine
okay yeah oh my God why am I unpacking
something really traumatic
I poured this very crisp glass of wine
and I was just so acutely aware that I
didn't want to suddenly start sipping it
um this is a lovely gavi that I'm
drinking right now still looks nice and
oh hang on I can talk while you drink
wine
um let me ask the question in a longer
way so you know you're an actor several
several years on Final Fantasy 16 but
that's not the extent of your acting of
course as you have experience
what are they
this is first of all thank you for
asking it anytime um and it's just it
was since it was phrased so well thank
you
um I started acting
professionally
after I left drama school so I went to
the London Academy of Music and dramatic
art and uh in London it's fancy I think
it's a fancy school it's a fancy School
lots of fancy actors went there great um
I was very lucky to be one of those
actors who kind of imagined being one of
those fancy actors
um
and uh
then but I started like wanting to be an
actor from about the age of nine maybe
um I I was very lucky I played gavrosh
the little urchin kid in Les Mis in the
National touring company of Les Mis oh
cool so that was my when I was 11 years
old I played for three months that's
awesome singing singing and dancing
around covered in covered in soot do
they pay you when you're 11 how does
that work they do they do pay me they
pay me that's great
Hey listen this is some expert this is
this is like inside a training
inside baseball I would say words on
sing on stage and they would give me
pounds like that and I would say thank
you so much and then I would put them in
my bank
um and yeah it was really fun I know
it's a really amazing concept that is
actually very cool though like as an 11
year old like so many kids dream of
getting to do that and you actually got
to do it that's awesome I felt I felt
bad because
um I just started my new school like the
like it was year seven so I don't know
what that would be in in the states I
don't like this to be fair uh year seven
for us is maybe primary school is one to
seven so this is the one after primary
school this is like the first year I've
seen you guys are the same as Australia
right it's Primary School in high school
yeah yeah so we're the same but we start
high school grade eight first year first
year of high school yeah
imagine this you are in class and your
treat
After High School is to go and see one
of your classmates in a three and a half
hour Musical
um and so that my class trip was to come
and see me perform Les Mis
and I was you didn't get a class strip
I didn't no I didn't get a class trip
but I was lucky because I also did all
the sports and all the stuff so I you
know they were kind of like oh Ben's the
you know that guy but I I felt really
bad because I forced all of my post all
of my new class to come and say I didn't
but the school thought it would be
educational for them to watch her a
musical about the French Revolution I
think 11 year olds [__] with Les Mis
they [__] hard they [__] up famous oh
big time I might have liked it I don't
know yeah
um I think I remember so vividly being
like fancying so much the woman who
played the older eponine like I was in
love with her and I think she kind of
knew because she gave me like some she
gave me like some nice sweets and things
and she was like she was like
I was being groomed yeah yeah no that
was not happen as I said it I went this
sounds like a grooming story yeah you
know I understand she just thought you
were a cute kid and she was being nice
to you yeah and I was obviously like 11
and absolutely in love with her because
she was incredibly talented and
beautiful and singing and just all the
above yes um yeah and I was also
terrified of the guy who played Javert
who's like the policeman and
interestingly interestingly not Stuart
Clark who plays Dion in the Final
Fantasy XV uh currently plays Javert on
the West End no way yeah yeah that's
cool um so there's a lot of Les Mis in
Final Fantasy 16 what kind of yeah yes
too much of anything
um so yeah and then I love songs but so
that that was your first technically
professional yeah work which is nuts
that that started very early
um and you just wanted to be an actor
the whole time and then ended up at
London like you just knew exactly what
your path was
yeah exactly from from 11 I knew that
was going to be an actor and then I went
to school did all the school stuff then
went to uh uh University knew that I
wanted to go to university and do
history
um and then I was like yeah that's I
want to go to drama school I just
applied and got in and it was this week
this strange thing where I was like well
I'm just gonna go to drama school I'm
going to go and I didn't think that
thousands of people apply and most of
them don't get in but but just part of
me just went no you'll be fine Ben
you're good enough what's the
application process then
um you would uh send in an application
and they would say yes we'd like you to
come down to London to audition and then
you would stand in front of a panel of
people and do a classical and a modern
piece so I did
I think I did
uh rumor from Henry IV part two
um which is a banging monologue
um about being the personification of
rumor it's really good and it still
holds up today and I also had my backup
which was a hamlet speech
um and then I did a as another speech
from the pillow man which is a Martin
McDonough play
um currently on the West End actually
with Lily Allen but it's Martin
McDonough it's about a totalitarian
state and it's an amazing quite
The Haunting play traditionally dark
like Martin McDonough
um and then yeah you do those pieces and
then you'd be really nervous and then
they would they would send you a letter
A Written Letter nice
yeah it's exactly like Hogwarts and and
it would be like a really nice thick
thick parchment do you still have it um
no I don't I would have kept it yeah I
know you're better than I am you're a
better person than I am no just
sentimental yeah keeping lettuce makes
me Superior
yeah I'm a hoarder yeah yeah now you've
got lovelies your room looks lovely
because you have a lot of stuff yeah
it's got together it took a while though
I wish I had a room like yours
I really wish I had already you probably
could
yeah I mean again now that I've said it
I regret saying which like I like I
covered your room I wish I could have
your room
um again you I mean you probably could
just you just put some plants in the
back there thank you so much
that is to talk about I've set it up in
the bedroom because downstairs it's just
it's just better to do all the stuff up
here so I've got like absolute chaos
behind this screen here
um I can't see it and no you that's the
great thing beautiful that's the great
yeah I shouldn't have said anything no
actually Illusions shattered now
everyone thinks you're a mess and
previously guys
yeah I wanted to give such a good
impression no everyone thinks you have a
messy room
oh no
I lost myself on the internet again
after drama school
[Music]
sure a lot of people follow that path
and people who listen to this podcast
you know a lot of uh people who do are
people who are interested in getting
into uh acting or voice acting
um yeah what's the process
to actually like find an agent or
management like how do you go from
school to working
it's there is no path to that it is all
it is it is all just luck and
Circumstance but my luck and
Circumstance went like this which is I
did a final year showcase and an agent
came to see me and then I went for an
interview and I was lucky to go to
Lambda like it's one of the best drama
schools in the world and so
they do a showcasing that all the agents
turn up because they want to see who the
next young things are and right so
you're kind of a shoe-in if you get to
go to that particular school you have
you have you have a great platform which
to Showcase your skills you are not
guaranteed an agent and even some of the
best actors that I knew who I trained
with didn't get agents because it's just
it's it's so crazy and random the
process but I was very lucky I mean
everyone has a different path and I
don't think any of them are easy
um
and there's no way to like force your
way into it uh but I suppose that your
Avenue there is
try and go to a good school
a pretty solid piece of advice to start
with
um there seemed to be a lot of people
who think they can skip the school part
but I imagine
you feel like learning is valuable I
tend to feel like learning is pretty
valuable
I like to learn
um I learned a lot at drama school I
learned a lot at drama school and I
didn't think I did
and now I just think about all of the
skills how you're applying them
yeah it's crazy it's just I I take for
granted all of the things that I have
learned throughout my education and
throughout my career that I would say to
someone who wasn't an actor and they
would be amazed that I know that stuff
but for me it's just stuff that you just
take in you absorb it and I don't think
I'm particularly knowledgeable about
anything really but I'm more
knowledgeable than I was 10 years ago
for sure you know I'm and I think that
you just pick all this stuff up like I
really do think acting you is a is a
doing it's you don't it's not a sit in a
study it is a doing is making mistakes
um I'm such a practical actor which is
you can give me 30 000 notes like I
won't listen to them I will listen to
one or two and take things that are
actionable within that
um
and often it will be what is what is the
action in this scene what do I need to
do and I'll play that and go okay that's
great and I will then interpret it
because that's all it is it's Alchemy
it's that it's the moment of the
combination of writing direction of
performance and how those come together
and all three people interpreting that
work in a way that you cannot predict
yeah
um and I firmly believe that and my
experience has always been just do it
and the best stuff that I've ever done
personally that I that I think got Ben
I'm really proud of that
um because I always speak about myself
in the third person yeah like it's very
important that's rule one always speak
about yourself in the third person if
everyone respects everything to do I
think yeah yeah it's it's just how you
command respect in this career yeah
um is keep if you take anything away
from this make sure it's that yeah
straight down the barrel of the lens
everyone talk about yourself in the
third person
um but it's it's the doing and I'm
I'm a big fan of playing I'm quite a
playful actor
um I like to joke around and be silly
but also when the time comes be is
incredibly serious as I possibly can but
with that play comes my willingness to
fail and be made a fool of
um so I don't mind
trying something and then just falling
on my ass because
I think it's a great way of
um
it's a great way of succeeding in ways
you never thought better to take a risk
and make the wrong choice than to make
consistently boring choices oh my God
absolutely and also don't
I got given this bit of advice from an
actor that I worked with quite early on
in my career which is the most
remarkable thing about you is you
because like don't try and give them
what you think they want give them what
you can do like don't predict what
someone wants from you
um and obviously take Direction and
there's room within that thing but like
you are what makes you interesting so
and no one else can do what you do
despite what you may think and um
I've always kind of taken that to heart
and thought yeah you know what I can I
am gonna I'm gonna do that and make a
choice
if you do anything just make one one
um because
the amount of actors you see that you go
you just haven't made any choices you've
used there is it's better to make a
um a game director Corey uh Studio
director creative director says this all
the time that that it it's better to
I've said all the time it's like I've
heard him say it once uh it's better to
shut up about it every day talking to us
about actors making choices uh better to
make a choice and be wrong about it than
to not make a choice and I think that
comes from like not making a choice you
can be boring or
um not have an understanding of who any
character is like it comes across as
you're reading a script rather than
playing a character and that's going to
serve you worse than like a director
giving you a note of like oh we need to
change this slight thing rather than the
whole thing is wrong which yeah some
people make strange choices though there
was a guy who submitted an audition for
um the character of Baldo who's just
sitting over there I think he was eating
a sandwich
uh during an audition or something like
that there's that famous scene obviously
the scene where he just watch him
silently to sandwich yeah and then there
he is
some choices are
a little odd but you've also got to
stand out in some way I feel like that's
such an intimidating part of
being an actor
is the amount of effort you can put into
learning lines and submitting a tape for
them to never contact you again
and like that's just never win any other
career it's
it just seems nuts it seems so me
so mean and it's something that I have
completely normalized in my head is that
I can get tapes through for stuff that I
think that like
I've done an amazing job on and I've put
days of work in and I put so much
thought and I've set the camera up and
I've edited the piece and I've sent it
off and I am just thrilled because of
the work that I've done
and then I will hear nothing anyway
nothing and then the project will happen
and go away and I'll go to somewhere
else and I can also do the opposite
which is I put zero work in I send the
tape off and I get the part
and there is no Rhyme or Reason to that
that seems to happen to Rahul a lot all
the time too he's like I get the ones
that I didn't put any effort into do you
do do you do you read on the other side
for you yeah oh great yeah because I
have to do a lot of reading
you give notes do you give notes I do
sometimes yes I will sometimes direct
but only if I'm allowed there's a thing
that I sometimes do
um
that I'm told is terrible etiquette uh
which is
giving a line read like I'll be like
just say it like this and then I say the
way I expect him to say it apparently
actors hate that yeah that's probably
the worst thing you can do to an actor
my bad
no but I like it I really do sometimes
and I would say this on I would I'd say
this on 16 sometimes but like
um Morgan who is just he's an amazing
director he's an amazing he works at a
company called schlock who um localized
like death stranding and Nino Cooney and
Dragon Quest and 16. and he Morgan is so
specific about the performance that he
wants
and um he's a brilliant director
um and he's incredibly passionate but
sometimes I would be saying something
and it wouldn't be he have an idea in
his head and because I got so close to
Morgan I would just say just tell me the
line reading yeah how do you want me to
say how do you want me to say it and
it'd be like that I'm going fantastic
because in his mind that's what it was
and I would and I would why is it not
okay other times
because I'm the etiquette surely is
don't you know you want the actor to be
able to express themselves yeah I guess
you're literally just telling an actor
exactly yeah how to act you're taking
any agency away from the performance I
however if I am banging my head up
against the wall I have no problems in
people telling me exactly how they want
me to say it I guess especially if
you're recording for as long as you did
like with 16 yeah it makes sense I'd
lose so much
of an understanding of a particular line
often because you say it so many times
there are some scenes in it like scenes
towards the end of the game
that I did in one take there are the
first take that we did like the ending
of the game
one take wow um and
um
yeah one take and it was that's just
because it just worked right there was
that it was raw it was real it was me
saying I'm gonna take a pun
I mean go for it and all the you know
everything's landed in the right way and
it felt really real and raw
um and there are other times where I
just wouldn't get it and it would be on
take 20 and I've gone I don't know what
these lines mean anymore they don't mean
anything and I and I like Naomi my um my
fiancee we we whenever we do tapes for
stuff we will kind of restrict ourselves
to maximum four takes
because otherwise it just doesn't it's
just you've lost it by that point yeah
you've absolutely lost it also this is a
bit of advice for any actors out there
the most important part of a self tape
is the first 10 seconds
that's it
that's what there are think about how
many tapes casting directors
they are they want they want to know
within 10 to 20 seconds they know
whether you're right for the part or not
yeah and so you can record eight minutes
but make sure that you've made those
choices I'm not saying you have to kind
of like jump on screen and go
um uh it would be weird weird Choice
well unless it says that in the script
in which case sabler no just shove it on
to shop at the beginning just to kind of
keep them on their toes and go this
guy's interesting
um uh yeah is is the first 10 20 seconds
but yes I've heard that before
um speaking of you know various
challenges what was the actual hardest
thing about playing Clive what would you
say was the single biggest challenge
um outside of the time span
what was the hardest thing that's
Progressive that is actually genuinely
no joke a very very good question thank
you I really appreciate that you're so
good at interviewing I'll slip yourself
that's really nice thank you that's all
um
uh what was the hardest thing well the
or the biggest challenge yeah I think
the the biggest challenge is kind of
myself in it like I think a lot of the
time I probably get in the way of myself
in it I'd overthink a lot of stuff enjoy
interesting um because I
I was both fortunate and unfortunate to
to love this franchise a lot it's a lot
of pressure
yeah and so I think I would often
break my own rule is like sometimes give
a performance or make a choice early on
that wouldn't be for me or the character
it would be in the service of something
else
um me imagining what the end product is
going to be instead of that so
interesting
yeah and I guess like when you're that
much of a big Final Fantasy fan you're
also probably thinking about every other
Final Fantasy fan and like not wanting
to disappoint them like I'm sure you
think about audiences and everything but
I feel like that's such a specific and
very hardcore audience very dedicated
fan base very dedicated fan base very
passionate fan base you know learning
that it's a very passionate fan base
yeah they have they have very strong
opinions about this franchise always
have yeah
um I am one of them and uh it's it's
just yeah it's hard not to it's hard not
to think am I ruining Final Fantasy
that is a lot
it is a lot and it was on it I felt like
it was on me and I really felt like it
was on me around launch like I was
really happy to go and talk to loads of
people and and promote this game because
I was really proud of all the stuff that
I'd done on it and the stuff that I'd
done with the team and the character
meant a lot but I was I was so
I was so hard on myself I think through
that process of and I and I I don't know
why maybe it's just I've I felt like I
was responsible for it I was letting
people down if it if it wasn't what they
wanted or stuff you know I think that's
actually a very human
response I don't think it's unusual that
you're it's unfortunate but I don't
think it's unusual that you responded
that way yeah and now it's now it's
great now I'm just jumping on and doing
silly memes and asking for tickets to
Barbie but like it's
what was your favorite thing about
working on it
um my fate my favorite thing was
um
oh God it's really these are these are
good questions I've never really thought
about it was my favorite thing my
favorite my favorite thing about working
on it was the fact that I um
the fact that I did the thing the fact
that this is gonna be
in anything in my life this would be top
five things you know when people are
like top five things you do in your life
this yeah like I the entire experience
was so all-encompassing because so much
happened to me in my life during the
making of it
um I have spoken about this before in
interviews but my dad died in the
process and like
maybe that's the hardest thing yeah you
know is is is that process of of trying
to
rebuild yourself whilst you're playing
someone else or like are you hiding
behind this character and I think can
that be cathodic in a way
hugely cathartic hugely cathartic
amazing to understand yourself and your
own
your own loss because it honestly it's
it's has and it continues it destroyed
me yeah in my life my biggest fear like
it sucks that my biggest fear is the
inevitability of my parents dying keeps
me up at night I'm so sorry yeah
there's nothing there's nothing to be to
be done about it I just had to it just
happened and you're left with kind of
like the pieces of your life
and then you have to pick yourself back
up and say
go and make some video games
um
somehow
um and uh that was really that was yeah
that was the hardest part but I was able
I was able to
I was able to hide behind it I think
hide behind the regime the regime
um
still World Choice there you go please
clip that
um
yeah just all the all the silly things
that I've said in the past few minutes
um I I was able I was able to hide
behind a routine of going to work every
single day
um and working on something and seeing
progress
um yeah in it and
because I was there every day because I
was so consistently a part of this
process I was let into the project in a
way that I wouldn't have been otherwise
this is a hugely strictly NDA project
project where no one would you're not
allowed to know anything but I think
because they knew me yeah and I was
there for so long that
I would have regular kind of like
monthly updates with Koji and he'd show
me like more finished versions of the of
the game maybe
yeah I did I did that's the thing that
like we probably don't give a lot of uh
actors enough credit for in video games
is like especially if you're the
protagonist you
are a part of the dev team in my opinion
if you are playing a character for four
years you are a part of the dev team
you're shaping the game uh and it's
weird that we like
disclude that
um when you can have so much input
that's so valuable and like you can give
a performance that will make somebody
rewrite a scene because they were like
oh he did that way better than it was in
my head it's uh yeah you you literally
developed a video game
and I I do feel that I do feel like
there are bits of this game where I go
that was I did that yeah I did that and
I love it for that and
um but obviously it is a huge process
you know this there are there are
hundreds thousands of people working on
these these things and you can only have
your own input to it but I would like
that more if that's possible I would
like actors
voice actors actors in video games to be
brought into the process more I think I
think it does tend to happen fairly
often for a very story driven
game for protagonist especially because
they're often cost quite early so that
they can help shape the rest of the
story
um but yeah I think it often doesn't for
the rest because I don't know if you're
aware Ben uh actors just keep leaking
[__]
oh do they I just announce games like
it's crazy it keeps happening and
someone would be like oh that wasn't
news yet like again an actor I think
Norman Reedus did it recently Norman
readers for DS2 yeah um didn't tone
didn't tone is it Tony Todd do it for um
the release date of Spider-Man yep
just keeps happening I say these things
and then they are proven to be stupid
comments well it's because you're all so
pretty you know you we don't we
shouldn't expect you to keep
dates or yeah you can't read how to use
contracts you know it's just we're
expecting too much that's us I just
poked my fingers around and I hope I'm
writing can you get line reads in your
game and that's how you know the screen
yeah yeah I have this all the time this
isn't for this there was actually
someone downstairs telling me what to
say you can't even speak actually yeah
it's no that's tough the performance is
very good I believe that you're saying
these things it took me four years
um I won't keep you for much longer and
partly because I have to get back to
work uh less so because you don't have
more questions yes very I'm very busy
and important
um I have way more questions than I
could ask but for uh my final questions
is just for generally for the audience
of the show
any extra advice for anyone who would
like to do what you do for a living or
get into
voice acting or acting in general
yeah persist
persist that's it because you never know
when it's gonna happen yeah
um I was doing acting and a lot of
people really want to work in video
games because it seems really cool but
whatever you want to do like you you've
got to really want it because you're not
going to succeed and the chances are you
will fail 98 of the time
you're experiencing
though the 0.1 percent of my successes
as an accent it just so happens to be
Final Fantasy it was the one yes that I
got you know
um
that's it is just b b
um be humble be nice
but I think being nice is super super
important but also be persistent and
understand that you are just going to
get knocked back and that's an awful
thing to come out of rejection
so much protection don't take it
personally it's hard it's hard to not
take it personally I have moments of
just
crippling weakness and crippling sadness
because I just I really wanted that yeah
am I not good enough for that it's so
you could just be too tall it can be any
little tiny thing that has nothing to do
with your performance at all and they'll
never tell you and you'll never find out
you you might have the wrong hair color
like they just didn't it didn't work it
has nothing to do with before I don't
know I just I don't envy the position
actors are in wearer
what it must do to
your self-esteem is concerned yeah yeah
and you sometimes you just go you've
just got to put yourself worth to one
side I've been talking to my therapist
about this
um it's about not necessarily like I am
Ben as I'm used to talking about myself
in the third person but I am I am more
than just being an actor my self-worth
is not is not directly connected to that
um and it's it's hard because you know
because for that one how do I not be
work what is that like I don't know how
to do that I am work Ben is work
um and it's it's very very hard not to
do that because you know I'd turn up to
a social event and they go what do you
do and I say I'm an actor and they go
what have I seen you in yeah and if they
haven't if they haven't seen you in
anything you are of no value to them
yeah and it's and it just happens it
happens so much the amount of times I
could say I'm in this video game right
now they're like oh I don't play games
is that a thing and I'm like yeah it is
and then I feel like I'm explaining
myself and I'm justifying what I do to
try and impress them but they don't care
and it's very difficult sometimes and
I'm pretty good at not falling into that
trap but you just get coaxed in you just
get coaxed in with it yeah that's tough
because it's even happening for like
just regular people not just uh people
trying to hire you like what have I seen
you in I don't know what have you seen I
don't know are you in anything I would
have seen I I have no idea
yeah that stuff yeah I don't know what
would I have seen you in anything as me
going I just don't know do you want me
to list my IMDb for you I don't just
pull it up it's QR code
yeah yeah and it's it's it's hard but um
oh my gosh she looks like a little teddy
bear
that's a very cute face he's a little
boy
oh there he is
perfect
yes he's been sleeping
oh thank you this is all I actually
wanted
that was the real final question
let me see your dog that should be the
final question of the show every time
actually I do have to uh get back to
work but where can people find you if
they would like to hear more from Ben
Starr you can find me in the critically
acclaimed video game final fantasy 16
but no you can uh I'm on uh social media
at the underscore Ben under squeeze
making his bed now the underscore Ben
underscore star on pretty much all of
the social media platforms and you'll
see me posting pictures with Milton or
just randomly talking about thoughts
that come into my head
um excellent about stuff and Melton and
hopefully mostly about mostly about
thoughts that come into Milton's head is
that ball for me
I'll leave links in the description uh
thank you so much for joining me today
Ben I appreciate you making the time
thank you for having me and
congratulations on the game it's quite
good
thank you all right bye everybody
[Music]